c'est un champignon très particulier et
surtout très recherchés une histoire qui
dure depuis l'antiquité c'est vous dire
on compte à ce jour plus d'une vingtaine
d'espèces de truffes en france et dans
notre région et bien on en trouve au sud
berry mais également au sud touraine
précisément aux confins du poitou là où
nous nous trouvons aujourd'hui on va
retrouver dans un instant un
trufficulteur il s'appelle jean manuel
rocher mais avant cela des archives les
images date de 1983 et à cette époque
les journalistes de centre actualitté eh
bien nous raconte que la récolte des
truffes est en baisse regardez
aussi que le dernier la france
produisait près de 2000 tonnes de
truffes par an sa production est
aujourd'hui tombée à 50 tonnes les
restaurateurs et les conserveries de
luxe en apporte autant d'espagne et
d'italie
la plaine de richelieu en indre-et-loire
fut même la première région truffières
de france bien avant le périgord grâce
au phylloxéra qui avait conduit à
l'arrachage des vignes
grâce à la pénurie de bois qui oblige à
se mêler gland la truffe trouva sur ses
sols pauvres un terrain idéal bonjour
jean manuel rocher alors je les dis vous
êtes trufficulteurs ici au sud touraine
grâce à vous on va tout savoir sur la
truffe mais d'abord un mot sur ce que
l'on vient de voir
1983 il y à 32 ans la production de
truffes est en berne qu'est ce qui s'est
passé c'est une région qui était dans
les première productrice de truffes et
je pense que c'est après la guerre de 14
qu' il ya eu cette perte de cultures et
de traditions de la truffe parce que les
gens ont eu un souci au retour de la
guerre c'est délire se chauffer et se
nourrir donc comme généralement les
truffières
naturel c'était des arbres qui étaient
pas trop jolie donc on a commencé à
arracher des bois qui n'étaient pas très
bons rapports si vous les forestiers
pour pouvoir faire des la culture à blé
pour pour se nourrir donc le déclin a
commencé là moi je les trouve en
labourant
c'est pour une solution enfin comme on
travaille pour faire les céréales en
général on les trouve sur le terrain
après quoi s'en aller chercher c'est à
dire que si c'était bien
bien cultiver nous aurions des truffes
tous les ans
peut-être pas en abondance sa dépendre
des années sèches mais en années humides
on aurait des truffes
raisonnablement il y avait aussi les
transformations agricole il n'y a pas
que la suppression des chaînes pour pour
pour cet agriculteur
oui parce que de toute façon
on a évolué vers des rendements de plus
en plus grands les remembrements été
fait aussi dans les régions donc si a
fait qu'on a des grandes parcelles alors
que souvent on trouvait la truffe et en
bordure de bois on en est où aujourd'hui
en 2015 au niveau des plantations je
pense que ça a continué à se développer
au niveau aux récoltes on en est
toujours à peu près à la même chose
m
on a rencontré quelqu'un que vous
connaissez bien il s'agit de christian
manach sur la piste des truffes avec
christian regardé et on en parle juste
après
cherche
cherche on cherche
non la question souvent c'est de savoir
à quelle profondeur la truffe se trouve
donc elle peut être juste en surface
comme les dernières ou alors carrément à
20 30 cm de profondeur ça dépend du sol
de la truffe on la voit bien à cause des
petites bêtes rouge qui sont à côté qui
sont des parasites qui se met dans la
truffe et ben voilà une petite
alors vous avez il suffit d'avoir un
chien bon vous avez des chiens qui sont
appelés le la gâteau qui est bon on dit
que c'est un chien est spécial pour la
truffe enfin n'importe quel chien qui a
du nez et qui est obéissant peut vous
faire un très bon chien truffier et de
la truffe c'est surtout un parfum s'il
ya un goût aussi mais l'important c'est
le parfum c'est pourquoi quand on la
travaille l'être il faut pas trop la
chauffer parce que le parfum ce temps là
combien ça vaut un kilo de truffes ou la
fourchette centre 350 euros aux 1200
euros le kilo mais vous n'avez pas
besoin d'acheter un kilo pour faire
plaisir un avec une truffiers ou faire
40 ou 50 g ça va vous coûter 35 euros
vous commencez déjà pour vraiment goûté
s'il ne savez pas ce que c'est la truffe
sur une petite tranche de pain un petit
peu grillé un petit peu en 2007 prenez
un economou de mandoline ou fait deux
trois petites rondelles de truffes vous
goûtez là vous allez savoir ce que c'est
que la truffe pour découvrir et ensuite
le restant de cette truffe ou mettez
dans un récipient avec des oeufs pendant
48 heures vous pourrez manger des oeufs
à la coque koroglu de truffes dès que
vous avez une trouve dans une pièce à va
tout de suite embaumé la pièce merci
infiniment jean bédel rocher en tout cas
vous nous avait mis l'eau à la bouche
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions et
nous on se dit à bientôt pour retrouver
la mémoire